مع تقدمهم في جبهات القتاده للسعاده
السيطره على خرص التي تحتلها روسيا
ليعتقدها هؤلاء الجنود الاوكرانيون ان
قوات موسكو ستتراجع دون قتال وقد غرقت
المدينه في ظلام دامس دون كهرباء او ماء
على الرغم من ان الاداره التي نصبتها
روسيا القطبي اللوم على اوكرانيا
لكن الامر كله مساله وقت لان الجماعه
الاوكرانيه تنفذها هجمات ارهابيه ستتم
سعادته الكهرباء قريبا وقد لاحظت قوتنا ان
لوكرانيين من الغرب ينتظرون الابلاغ عن
تحرير مدينه خرسان
في العاصمه كيف ومناطق اخرى استهدفت
الضربات الجويه الروسيه البنيه التحتيه
للطاقه حيث يعيش اكثر من اربعه ملايين شخص
دون كهرباء ولم تنجح اجراءاته ترشيد
الطاقه لتجنب انقطاع التيار الكهربائي
شركه الطاقه الوطنيه
نسمه خلال الشهر الماضي دمرت روسيا نحو
40% من مشاهدات الطاقه